[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance he said quote you'll find out
on Tuesday or Wednesday he said he knows
a lot about hacking he said he knows
about the hacking of the Democratic
National Committee and other computer
systems quote things that other people
don't know what do you know he was asked
Saturday night that other people don't
know you'll find out he said confidently
on Tuesday or Wednesday but Tuesday
night he tweeted that the intelligence
briefing on Russian hacking he put
insult quotes around intelligence and
Russian hacking had been delayed until
Friday positing perhaps more time needed
to build a case very strange later
Tuesday night CNN reported there had
been no hacking review scheduled that
day for Trump by the CIA director nor
the Director of National Intelligence
NBC reported there was one but it had
always been scheduled for Friday
independent reporter Marc am binder
reported there was a scheduled briefing
that was delayed from last week because
of the family emergency of one of the
intelligence officials that the White
House would get that briefing Wednesday
congressional leaders Thursday and Trump
Friday and it was identical to what
Trump would have heard last week Trump
has said nothing except to again attack
other Americans and to again pretend he
knows everything and Wednesday morning
to incredibly to take sides with Julian
Assange who is an enemy to this country
and an enemy to democracy everywhere and
at best a de facto Russian agent Julian
Assange said a fourteen-year-old could
have hacked Podesta why was DNC so
careless also said Russians did not give
him the info and quoting Fox News Julian
Assange on US media coverage it's very
dishonest more dishonest than anyone
knows the dishonesty here is all Donald
Trump's with Assange for whom Trump
wanted the death penalty in 2010 and the
cretan Hannity as his fellow-travellers
we the American people the victims of
Trump's disloyalty and his deranged
attempt to position himself as the only
person who knows the truth have found
out nothing in the four days since Trump
began to play this ridiculous dangerous
unamerican game we still have no idea
what those things are that he
supposedly knows that other people don't
nor who told them to him and we are
waiting this was not just his usual
boast not just as usual dismissal of
this country's intelligence services not
just as usual lie about the intelligence
community and the Iraq weapons of mass
destruction which was not failed
intelligence but rather intelligence
manipulated and altered and falsified
and turned on its head by the Bush
administration this was a man not three
weeks before taking power insisting this
country should not investigate what the
Russian dictator did to our election a
man demanding that the rest of us from
John McCain to me need to get on with
our lives a man suggesting again he also
said this in July that the best response
to computer hacking that might have
altered the course of history was to
stop using computers and to go back to
using messengers this is a man on the
eve of ultimate power in our country
still insisting Russia is right and
America is wrong and he knows quote a
lot about hacking and he knows things
that other people don't know and you'll
find out on Tuesday or Wednesday trump's
silence through tuesday and now
wednesday and now based on this tweets
presumably through friday leaves him
very few ways out of this ludicrous
boasting unless by friday you have
forgotten about all this his incoming
press secretary Sean Spicer already so
far in over his head he needs a scuba
suit flailed around the other day trying
to walk back Trump's boast and to
suggest the tin-pot Tire intellect was
really talking about conclusions he had
reached from classified briefings this
excuse might have worked if Trump had
not spent so much time explaining he
does not attend need nor worry about
classified briefings you'll find out on
Tuesday or Wednesday well we have not
and of course even if we had found out
even if we yet do find out Trump will
still have painted himself into an
impossible corner just a different
impossible corner about the hacking
quote I know things that other people
don't know who told them to you Trump if
it's from American intelligence briefers
you said you don't believe them if it's
from American intelligent briefers why
are you revealing or merely
Fritzing secret classified information
weeks before you're legally permitted to
do so if it's not from American
intelligence briefers who was it from
was it flat amir putin did he tell you
russia didn't hack the DNC and try to
swing the election so it would have you
in office
how long did Putin know how long has it
been since he told you did he tell you
this before the election Trump why have
you not told America why did you not
tell America even just last Saturday
night or Tuesday instead of another
tweet worthy of a snot-nosed teenage boy
did Putin tell you not to tell us why
did you agree to conspire with Putin to
conceal this information even if it has
only been concealed since last Saturday
did you inform American intelligence of
what Putin told you and if so how
quickly did you do that Trump what are
the things you know that other people
don't Trump were not told to you by
American intelligence nor by Putin who
then how do they know who told them why
have you not told America what they knew
is your hacking source General Michael
Flynn who reads and believes and
disseminates conspiracy theories bluntly
insane conspiracy theories about
pedophilia and Sharia law and Democrats
ritually drinking body fluids is your
hacking source Julian Assange Hooper
Speaker of the House Ryan steals and is
a quote sycophant for Russia and has
long since lost any credibility of
unconservative Zora liberals is your
hacking source Trump Alex Jones the
radio nut who believes Sandy Hook never
happened and the dead bodies there were
child actors is your hacking source the
National Enquirer who you parotid when
it claimed Ted Cruz's father was
involved in the Kennedy assassination if
you're hacking source the individual you
have repeatedly cited as a computer
expert your ten-year-old son or your
hacking source and the things you know
that other people don't know and the
part about Tuesday or Wednesday and the
part of a delayed briefing that was
reportedly never scheduled in the first
place did you just make them up because
you thought we were all too stupid to
expect you to deliver in the summer
Trump insisted the election was rigged
in the autumn the intelligence community
conclusions that maybe he was right in
the winter Trump suggests we should not
hold hearings to see if the Russians
subverted our freedoms by remote control
in a tux on New Year's Eve Trump insists
about the hacking that I know things
that other people don't know and you'll
find out on Tuesday or Wednesday in a
peevish tweet on Tuesday night he throws
up another accusatory smokescreen by
writing perhaps more time needed to
build a case very strange and in his
most disturbing tweet yet on Wednesday
morning he defended a man facing a
sexual assault charge in Sweden and
probable espionage charges here and he
attacked the men and women who defend us
so now we need to have not just hearings
about the hacking we need hearings about
what Trump meant last Saturday night
what he knew why he promised to reveal
it and why he is concealing it now in
short to revise a great question from
history what did Donald Trump know and
when did he stop knowing it resist peace